Welcome back everyone it's charlie Shang Chi
the legend of the 10 rings is out.
I know you have lots of abomination questions
this is going to be my video all about what's
going on with the abomination during the Shang
Chi movie.
The director and the producers of this said
it's just meant to be a teaser for big things
that are happening for him in the future Marvel
phase 4.
So we'll break it all down.
If you're brand-new to the channel, be sure
to subscribe to get all the videos there's
a bunch of really big stuff coming up in obviously
careful for spoilers for the Shang Chi movie.
If you have not seen it yet.
Because will be talking about some really
spoilers stuff but when Shang Chi and Katy
go to Macau to find his sister mistakingly
thinking that she contacted him with the postcard
of the great protector Dragon Jon-Jon explains
this whole big operation is very reminiscent
of the operation that Sharon Carter builds
is the power broker inside madripoor if that
when they first released the trailer and we
saw some of these scenes out of context.
A lot of people mistakenly thought that it
was meant to be madripoor we find out that
his sister Charlene ran away from home at
the age of 16 it came to Macau to set this
fighting ring operation she's turned into
this whole big thing is obviously meant to
foreshadow the turn where she takes over the
10 rings organization in the post credit scene
they pass about the low level fights, including
the extremist soldier from iron man three
fighting one of the former liberated black
widows from the black widow movie sort of
foreshadowing the Trevor reveal just another
connection to Iron Man three.
The last big Marvel movie to invoke the Mandarin
even though the way they explain it in this
movie when we were never called himself the
Mandarin in they turned the name into an even
bigger joke this movie is also being released
right after the black widow movie.
But the black widows that Natasha and yelena
belova free with red Guardian and Melina happen
years ago during 2018.
Right before the events of Avengers infinity
war.
So you have to remember the time jump this
is happening in 2023 so that black widow had
not been snap she would been participating
this underground fighting scene for years
same thing for the extremist soldier the events
of Iron Man 3 Took place back in 2013 10 years
ago but then they reveal wall and finding
the abomination in the main ring.
Like the big fight Mortal Kombat style for
the big money that is an awful lot a sandwich
money that Wong just one himself.
Yes it's super cool cameo scene.
But the bigger twist is that as they fight,
it actually seems like long is almost coaching
the abomination he seemed kind of pulling
his punches so to speak.
Metaphorically, then literally like he pulls
the abominations punch through a portal so
that he knocks himself out as they fight he
says you want to know how it feels on the
show you how it feels the abomination isn't
quite as powerful as the Holt almost as powerful
as a hoax was used on all the trailers he
is able to smash one of one's magical shields
like that's how strong he is Wong seems really
pissed off like he was expecting him to pull
his punches a little bit that's why he pulls
this trick on the abomination causing him
to punch himself and knock himself out.
He calls abomination by his real name Emil
Blonsky and even though you can't tell that
much just from watching the movie Tim Roth
did come back to do some vocalization for
the character during the movie.
He was also at the movie premiere so that
is him making all those noises and those grunts
when they're fighting and they model Tim Roth's
face for motion capture for the abomination here
Even though he looks a little bit different.
I've talked about this in previous videos
already.
But the reason why the abomination looks different
now is they just made him more comic book accurate
If you not a big comic book reader are which
is been a long time since you've read those
original incredible whole comic books.
This is exactly what the abomination looks
like in the comics, the coloring of his skin
down to the fins on his head.
His pointed teeth within the context of the
MCU though is most likely that his gamma mutation
just continue to evolve and change his body
over time at a slower rate.
Like the initial dose of gamin serum that
he was given during incredible Hulk turn them
into this during that movie.
But that was back in 2008 cut to 13 years
later in his body just continue to change
until it looks like this the real reason why
they changed in though was because back when
they made the original incredible Hulk movie,
they were just playing it safe try not to
make too many weird looking characters.
The director claimed he didn't like the fins
now that they've done rocketing route to super
popular Marvel characters on the people are
totally down for talking raccoons and talking
trees the super weird stuff often, winds up
being the most popular stuff Kevin Feige says
that nowadays they feel safer doing the super
weird stuff look alligator Loki was not something
that they would've tried back during Marvel
phase 1 and now in present day.
He's one of the biggest fan favorite Loki
variants superior Loki, but they take this
one abomination thing even further.
Like he almost seems like he's Brose with
the abomination like their mates and they
been hanging out for a while now, then they
have this joke about a bunch of dues having
to drag him out of the ring because he so
big and heavy after their fight in the locker
room just a moment later Wong asked him how
his jaw is like how you doing buddy and opens
a portal to a special high-tech facility where
there's a special containment cell with a
bunch of lasers designed to hold it looks
very reminiscent of the one that Nick fury
built to contain the Hulk in the first avengers
movie.
He tells him that he needs to learn to control
his punches.
Like they practice confirming that Wong has
been doing this with abomination for a good
long while now in SI explain the timeline
of the movie.
This takes place around the time falcon and
winter soldier's happening.
But before Spider-Man Far From Home, and Spider-Man
No Way Home.
So several months after avengers endgame everyone's
asking why has Wong been working with the abomination
It just seems like a super weird thing to
do really something more is going on here
than Wong just wanting to earn some more sandwich
money.
I think is pretty clear from the look of the
facility that he takes him back to that this
is supposed to be the raft.
Because that's where he was taken after the
events of the incredible Hulk.
According to Kevin Feige, but they just kept
him there all the way through avengers infinity war
The snap the blip in avengers endgame.
So whatever he's been doing this whole time,
they always at least take him back to the raft
Even though he's only in the movie for a hot
second the producers said that this is only
the beginning for the abomination in Marvel
phase 4.
So I think were probably all in agreement
this is all meant to be set up for a Val scene
is similar to the black widow post credit
scene they explained that he's either been
working for Val for a long time already like
the way yelena belova was we saw her show
up or Val is going to show up and recruit
him.
When he comes back in the she Hulk series
because that is the next place they confirmed
abomination is coming back.
According to Kevin Feige Mark Ruffalo's Bruce
Banner and his holder also coming back for
that to for she holds origin story and is
also probably why Banner showed up during
the post credit scene as well.
Because when you're picking whose going to
show up in avengers post credit scene how
do you pick usually want to T something that's
happening really soon.
And a lot of what happens in the post credit
scene is foreshadowing for future Avengers 5 stuff
Which we won't see for a long time in for
instance, the reason Captain Marvel showed
up in that post credit scene even though Captain
Marvel to the marbles movie with the multiple
versions of Captain Marvel isn't going to
happen for a good long while.
Is because Daniel Cretton the director of
the Shang Chi movie had worked with Bree Larson
a lot in the past and they were friends and
he just said oh you know whatever the post
credit scene, winds up being I would love
to work with Brie Larson again.
So if you're wondering why they did it avengers
zoom call like they did during avengers endgame.
That's why they did it that way because they
had to explain how Captain Marvel could be
there get still be on the other side of the
galaxy increase crawl space.
They also said that they pick the characters
that were going to be in the post credit scene
at the last minute.
Like that was literally the last thing that
they film for the movie during re-shoots so
Kevin Feige and Marvel wanting to tease what's
happening next and she Hulk is the reason
why Bruce Banner was in that post credit scene
specifically the whole thing with abomination
during she Hulk though is that the series
is actually being billed is a half-hour legal
comedy type of show.
Even though I don't think that is going to
be a comedy straight up.
Like they're playing up the idea that she's
a lawyer for superheroes in the Marvel universe.
That's why it's going to be a nine episode
series because it's going to be closer to
the episode length of Wandavision.
But even though she's a lawyer her normal
gamma form is always closer to being more
like Professor Hulk's gamma form.
Like she rarely went full incredible Hulk.
So she spends most of her time as an 8 foot
tall green lawyer who superstrong but also
has all of her mental capacity and intelligence
is Jennifer Walters and because the lawyer
part of it all.
They kind of tease that they're going to be
doing different cameos in different episodes.
Like different cases in different episodes
in the use that to cameo different Marvel
characters abomination might be one of her
cases in that's why he's back for the series.
But also as part of that the weave in the
Val thunderbolts and dark avengers of it all
also I hope that they tease a big Hulk versus
abomination rematch, but will see because
the whole banner of it all.
Like he's turned back into Banner now from
Professor Hulk.
I know there a ton of questions about that
to get remember the banner can control his
gamma form and even though he had an agreement
with the Hulk like that's why they became
Professor Hulk because the Holt wanted to
be free.
But Banner also wanted to be in control as
well.
I don't do they plan on killing him off or
anything like that anytime soon.
I think part of the reason why he's banner
here is one because they didn't want to spend
the extra money.
But the extra couple million dollars it would
cost to do him his motion capture is a full
version of the Hulk because even though they
do have a big budget for the movie that is
super expensive is way easier to have just
look is banner and shop with the sling and
I think that budgetary consideration also
factors into the way they're going to use
him during the she Hulk series.
Like yes he will Hulk out at some point during
the she Hulk series, but is probably going
to be banner for a lot of that to just because
it's way cheaper to have them walk around
is banner with the whole vibe of abomination
during the Shang Chi movie is her trying to
give him more of an antihero arc in the MCU
instead of the strata villain.
The way they ended with his character in the
incredible Hulk film is also possible early
theory that they pay off some of that thunderbolts
dark avengers stuff during Captain America
for because clearly all the Val stuff in all
these different movies and Disney plus series
is building up to something bigger.
Like when we actually going to see abomination
running around with John Walker US agent Baron
Zemo yelena belova all the other Marvel antiheroes
that shall theoretically put on that team
event Julia Louis Dreyfuss was also seen recently
getting ready to film near Atlanta where they're
filming Black Panther to.
So a lot of people are theorizing that she's
going to show up during Black Panther to to
recruit another villain from that movie.
Let me know in the comments you think that
might wind up being.
It also because we know from the black widow
post credit scene with yelena belova will
be a big part of the Hawkeye series were going
to see those episodes later this year, Val
also might show up again during the Hawkeye
series.
If you remember
The big Disney plus event happened last year
when they release all those trailers that
there were whole bunch of trailers that they
dumped looking to be doing the exact same
thing later this year in November.
So when I do videos for all those brand-new
trailers for all the upcoming Disney plus
series will probably give us release dates
for some of that stuff I'm working on a new
video for Avengers 5 and all the stuff that
they set up with that in the post credit scene
obviously everyone still wondering about where
that signal is broadcasting two from inside
the 10 rings and what's going on with them
that should post the next couple of days make
sure you have alerts enabled so you don't
miss that my full Marvel what if episode 5
video will also post Wednesday just like normal
everyone click here for my Shang Chi post
credit scene video and click here for my full
Shang Chi breakdown video with Easter eggs
for the entire movie.
Thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and I'll see in the next video!